a last shout for jose manuel barroso in
parliament offering his last state of
the union address before elections next
year
after which he was stepped down as
european commission president
in stark contrast this time last year
news of europe's embryonic recovery was
very much on his mind
the most vulnerable countries are paying
less to borrow
industrial output is increasing the
business outlook is steadily improving
consumer confidence is sharply rising he
continued with a rhetorical confidence
booster do we draw confidence
to pursue what we have started or do we
belittle
the results of our efforts the need to
capitalize on the small window of
opportunity
was also on some group leaders
but really cause for celebration is the
glass really half full
or with so many unemployed cast into
poverty
actually half empty show the reality of
europe
show that the glass is not only half
full it's also half empty still
we have still a lot to do and to change
the policies also of the commission
and others too warned that the light at
the end of the tunnel might in fact be
an oncoming train
this crisis is not over this
first signs of recovery are more the
proof of the fact
that we hit the bottom of the recession
and that means that we enter in what i
call a second
phase of this crisis and not to forget
the people at the bottom of the pile
europe's increasing numbers of the poor
one of the four
european is at risk of poverty or social
exclusion
and failing to acknowledge that it's the
european policies that have
made that possible makes it impossible
for ordinary europeans to even listen
to what jose manuel to the right they
weren't impressed either
though for different euro skeptical
reasons we need
a new euro realist direction with
different
ideas perhaps we could rediscover the
principle of freedom
that many in europe fashioned for the
world next year's elections
will offer us an opportunity